just start you don't have to have it all
figured out you don't have to do it
perfectly but the more plant foods that
you're building onto your plate and and
the more you're minimizing these animal
foods and these processed foods that are
making us sick the better off you're
going to be
[Music]
what's going on everybody who's Klauss
it in fantasies in rich role
good to see you Klaus according to Men's
Health magazine you're the world's
fittest vegan right right I would take
quite an issue with being dubbed the
world's fittest vegan I'm a fit vegan
hardly would call myself the fittest
vegan though plenty of super fit vegans
out in the world do you think it's like
a conspiracy to make veganism if that's
fair I'm kidding well I think I think it
I think it generates traffic when you
have a hyperbolic title and be pretty
good story right mmm
that's for you to judge I think you've
gotta get I give comfort from adversity
and been through a lot like different
kind of careers if you just kind of talk
about yeah sure so so I'm 51 now when I
was 39 I was 50 pounds overweight I was
a classic junk food addict I would just
eat anything in sight classic couch
potato kind of sliding into middle aged
a little depressed about my life and
certainly not fit or interested in
health or wellness or anything related
to the vegan movement I can tell you
that and I had a health scare shortly
before I turned 40 and it was a moment
where I realized I needed to take
inventory of how I was living and that
set me on a path that ultimately led me
to the plant-based lifestyle and that
really changed my life in every
imaginable way I would have talked about
the lifestyle bit a little bit later but
can you talk about like your sporting
accolades achieve so I was a swimmer in
college first and foremost I swear I'm
at Stanford in the late 1980s at a
pretty high level but when that chapter
was over that was it and I also have
another part of my story is a protracted
battle with alcoholism that I think
prevented me from reaching my potential
as an athlete at that time so I
rediscovered fitness in my 40s and went
on to compete in and place quite highly
in a number of ultra endurance
triathlons most notably a race called
Ultraman which is a three-day double
Ironman distance triathlon that
circumnavigates the entire Big Island of
the whole of Hawaii over over a
three-day period
and more recently I think in 2017 you
achieved something pretty big right yes
well in 2017 I did a race called Oh till
Oh
as the Americans would say it's actually
pronounced to the it's a Swedish event
it's the World Championships of
something called swim run and it's a
race that takes place every year in the
Stockholm archipelago where competitors
traipse across about 50 Islands spread
wide across the Baltic Sea
so you're swimming and you're running
jumping into freezing cold water and
swimming across these waterways and then
screwing up on it these Islands running
across them and jumping back in the
water you do the whole thing in a
wetsuit with your running shoes on and
yes I competed in that this past year do
you think that is a correlation between
coming from adversity and achieving a
lot especially in like the athletic
world there's definitely a correlation I
can only speak from my own experience
but there's definitely a correlation
between adversity and I think the drive
that I have to push myself to to my
limits both professionally and
athletically I've faced and had to
overcome quite a bit of personal
challenges over the years not just
emotional and mental but you know
spiritual financial like the whole kid
caboodle almost being the lifestyle
formula in particular whiffed I say
we're talking like just glance right
yeah just plants nothing with a face
nothing with a mother eating plant-based
foods as close to their natural state so
what kind of food should people avoid
people should avoid all animal products
they should avoid Gary Gary is not a
health food despite what you may have
heard and if I can go out and kill it at
age 51 and do things athletically that
most people are not interested in I
think it speaks pretty loudly to the
power of plants to fuel you to whatever
performance you're seeking to achieve in
your own athletic pursuits why do you
think there's so many misconceptions
about the vegan diet I guess I think
busting these myths yeah there's a lot
of fear there's a lot of misconceptions
and there's a lot of very powerful
corporate interests that are very
invested in keeping us wed to these
foods that are on
healthy whether it be you know red meat
products chicken even fish all the dairy
products this is huge business and so
there's a lot of money being funneled
into ensuring that we are deluded into
this idea that these have a place on a
healthy plate crazy appropriate protein
yeah where do you get your protein is
the question I get every single day I
get my protein from plants we can go
down the rabbit hole on all the myths
and misconceptions about protein but
essentially if you're eating plant foods
a wide variety of plant foods you're
just not gonna have a problem eating
your protein needs most people are
walking around consuming two to five
times the amount of protein they should
be eating and it's just never been an
issue for me I continue to get stronger
faster I've never had an issue building
lean muscle mass and I've been
plant-based for 11 years at this point
Wow I feel like there's so much more
information now about the plant-based
lifestyle compared to 11 years ago could
you just speak about that kind of not
transformation that like evolution of
the movement I guess you could say yeah
it's been an incredible evolution
there's never been more interest or
intrigue or fascination with the
plant-based vegan movement as there is
right now that certainly was not the
case when I began and what's great is
anybody who's watching this can go on
Netflix or on YouTube and watch
documentaries and there's no shortage of
amazing books out there that will answer
any question that you might have and
it's been very gratifying for me and I'm
sure for you as well Klaus to see so
many people jumping into this movement
and experiencing the tremendous results
that that it offers so I'm really
optimistic and excited about the future
what do you think like the key engine is
being recently it's kind of driven that
I think film is being a big one right
yeah a recent slate of documentaries I
think have been hugely impactful from
what the health and cowspiracy happy the
way you feed you tonight yeah I love
those guys you know it was great to have
a little cameo in that movie but I think
also I think that with this internet
culture that we live in now people's
[ __ ] Raiders are very finely attuned
and they're able to sniff out the
difference between fact and fiction
and I think people are sick and tired of
being sick and tired they're looking for
something that's real that's going to
address their health concerns that are
that is going to allow them to live in a
more sustainable fashion with respect to
the health of our planet and look we're
all born and bred compassionate human
beings nobody likes the idea of killing
animals for our food and once the lights
go on and you realize you don't have to
take part in that aspect of our culture
it's kind of a it's an amazing and
epiphany that people have that sort of
propels them to invest themselves more
deeply in this lifestyle mm-hmm for sure
and for people watching that might be
like I get what he's saying I get what
rich is saying but like there's a gap
between knowing how to do and actually
like doing it what would he say to those
people yeah I mean that's what my work
is all about is is bridging that gap
between information and action and I
think what really hamstrings people and
prevents them from taking those actions
is fear and also perhaps this sense that
if they don't do it perfectly then they
fail everybody who's vegan or
plant-based didn't just snap their
fingers and do it perfectly overnight
it's an evolution it's a journey for
everybody and that's gonna look
different depending upon who you are
where you live what your social
circumstances are what your economics
look like so my sort of edik to
everybody watching is just start you
don't have to have it all figured out
you don't have to do it perfectly but
the more plant foods that you're
building onto your plate and and the
more you're minimizing these animal
foods and these processed foods that are
making us sick the better off you're
gonna be and when you start to feel the
results you'll be more emotionally
invested in in this adventure and you
can go from there so don't hold yourself
to a perfectionist standard and don't
allow that to be a barrier to just
moving forward and jumping in with both
feet
for sure feel like we spoken a lot about
the the diet aspect and what we
recommend for people that want to get
fit and healthy for people that want to
get fit and healthy it's it's there's no
huge mystery honestly like I think that
the more you're eating foods that are
very nutritionally done
that are high in phytonutrients and
micronutrients the better off you're
going to be the more alkaline sort of
forming foods that you eat those are
what are going to reduce the
inflammation in your body and allow it
to recover more quickly in between
workouts I'm a big fan of green
smoothies that I make in a high powered
blender every morning with tons of kale
and spinach beets and berries all kinds
of fruits and vegetables tons of fiber
and that seems to really fuel me and
help me recover more quickly and don't
be afraid to eat a lot of food it's not
a deprivation diet people who come to me
and say I'm trying to be fit and I'm
trying to be an athlete but I'm scared
I'm not gonna meet my protein needs or
I'm gonna wither away that has not been
my experience whatsoever what about your
exercise split what are you doing right
now I'm not training for any specific
race I've got an idea that I'm playing
around with in my head for next year
that I'm not ready to talk about right
now so training right now is pretty
chill but I go out everyday and I run
bike or swim or I hit the gym I do core
work all the trails around here that's
my favorite thing to do is get out on
the trails so a lot of running at the
moment tips for people that want to get
fanta tips for people that want to get
fit or people say what's the best
exercise you know the best exercise is
the one you're actually gonna do it
should be a love affair it shouldn't be
perceived as a burden so I think the
first piece of advice I would give to
somebody is figure out what you enjoy
doing that involves moving your body it
doesn't have to be this painful thing
that you dread every day it should be
something that you look forward to and
yeah when you're out of shape sort of
that period of trying to get in shape
will require a little discomfort but
once you achieve a base level of fitness
I think you'll find yourself looking
forward to it and I think the key thing
and I think the thing that's been sort
of a secret not really a secret but a
recipe of my success equation is
consistency it's not about going out and
just crushing it you know in the gym or
putting in some massive workout it's
what you're doing every single day it's
the little things that you're doing
every single day that are moving you
forward in the direction of your fitness
goals mm-hmm sure and what's your
favorite part of training and you
your least favorite part my favorite
part is just the alone time it's like an
active meditation you know there's just
it's just it's just a beautiful thing to
be out on a trail at dawn and feel the
Sun of my on my shoulders and and just
the peace that comes with that
it's something I really look forward to
that's my favorite part them and what
the least favorite part is probably when
let's see what would be the least fit I
love it all like there isn't there isn't
really a least favorite part but there
are times where I don't want to get out
of bed you know and so then I have to
really rely on my you know my sort of
reserves of will to kind of get me out
the door and I've developed some mental
tricks around that but when you can kind
of overcome those barriers and just do
it I never come back from a workout and
say I wish I hadn't done that once
you're moving then you're like yeah
exactly yeah yeah sure so and with
veganism right now there seems to be
this kind of like mainstream appeal
mm-hm I'm just wondering like whether
there's been you mentioned film earlier
but whether there's been anything in the
last few months so yeah that kind of
just really gives you hope for the
movement I think it's really cool when
you see people who are prominent in our
culture adopting the lifestyle and being
mouthpieces for it like right now
recently will.i.am has has adopted a
vegan diet and he goes on his Instagram
and he talks about it was such passion
and for somebody of his stature who
wields so much influence over you know
how people think and behave like his
cultural significance is so massive I
think that's really cool and we're
seeing more and more of that not just
with you know musicians and entertainers
but also with athletes not just you know
skinny runner guys like me but
professional athletes in every
discipline from the NHL or the NBA to
the NFL and I think that's really
exciting because athletes hold this
special place in this in this
conversation which is that it doesn't
really matter what they say but it's how
they move their bodies and when they
perform at a high level they become very
powerful ambassadors of this movement
your favorite athletes
oh man you're gonna yeah that's good I'm
going to get
trouble if you make me answer that
question I can't answer that question
there's so many of them out there but I
think I think you know I think it's
great that you see guys like Kyrie
Irving and as a dunno Charo plays for
the Bruins who's all about it right now
I think that's really cool you know look
the the the most accomplished ultra
runner of all time Scott Jurek he's got
a new book coming out called North where
he conquered the the world record for
the Appalachian Trail like there's
countless examples of athletes out there
just crushing it in every conceivable
way in their various specialties on a
vegan diet and I think that's a super
cool he's the fittest who's the fittest
vegan I I can't answer that question
I'll tell you what I'll tell you who
it's not it's about me thanks to the
speech takes a wagon always great stuff
you've got your podcast which is killing
it yeah
so everything I do is that rich worldcom
podcast rich world podcast you can find
on we're now on YouTube but you know
wherever you listen to podcasts and then
I'm just at rich roll and Instagram
Twitter
[Applause]
[Applause]